welcome to this blitz game against ESO :
ya piece of call this was this is so
cool in this is the name of the sky
right Lyon it's so cool in you know
let's do something else not the Bogle
all of the time Queens Union
it's not that common nowadays the
Queen's Indian people mostly play the
Queens gambit declined on the top level
when they get this night a three
business 393 but it's still obviously a
perfectly good opening interesting and
this is this line is very much looking a
lot like a Sicilian can I do something
my my 56 as possible right okay so he's
ready for playing f4 I was I wanted to
play with h4 and so on but hmm yeah I
wonder if I if I can't afford a move
like g5 or if this is really really bad
okay and if it's not working in the
whole concept this is really bad
so here and G for next year
so deform this and whether it no other
idea it's the only way to keep the Queen
on e5
you know that that's that's typical
typical idea the real problem is that
hmm if it takes then place ie 5 I've got
Queen age 6 for them for the trade maybe
it's not that bad actually if I'm just
canceled here
the Queen trade is very important
yeah hmm it's still not so great right
check him let's start with that and then
see I can go H floor it's one
possibility something like with f4 ok
let's let's play this kind of solid move
maybe d6 is a simple way to do this
they cannot double on the DL now because
Ephraim hangs Jarno d6 maybe for a
simple position yeah come on this is a
keep it simple approach which shouldn't
be bad maybe this bad yeah I totally did
not see that one
ok md5 it's not that terrible okay I was
thinking f6 here should be the way for
counter play
check
yeah he played that well what can I say
and even quickly
time warning for the game these six
moves really what's the issue right I
mean I was under pressure before of
course but still this was the real
problem
ya have to go for activity
everything else is some it's not going
to be like working anyway so I have to
be active and well this is not that
terrible right Jake's here check
ah what a rotten game I really hate it
yeah when you when your worst remove one
and have to suffer really check alright
so this is very easy
yeah this was very very stupid okay come
on Wow okay so so not these six
obviously this cannot really be that bad
I mean I actually thought that I should
be better here but hmm didn't
materialize so f5 is what the computer
wants to do I thought my backbone
structures is not bad but it didn't
really have successful is much better
here I mean not much better as in better
for black but much better than the game
for this yeah this target on the f2
square the pawn and this I mean surely
isn't this isn't like totally terrible
that it leads to it leads to some
troubles f6 then you played this King
here and King euphoria that is better
for Wyatt you can whatever you want this
is better for white check
check now I cannot they cannot improve
him yeah I mean maybe maybe this maybe
it's nothing that I should be huge
necessarily but I think actually he let
me into him into it pretty well here man
this is this is stop not not a problem
anymore why didn't I take I can take a
three yeah why didn't I take a three
what Wow
I must have been hallucinating yeah I
can just take a three of course I saw
that he does it does he plays he plays a
4 I can just take and it's it wrong okay
well I was I was on the ropes here all
the time in the zoo end game so it's
probably a deserved Lawson Jack Jack so
I have to go f6m I really couldn't
believe that justice should be any
problem in a way I mean at least it
should be okay I went yeah yeah okay I
could have taken this was also also
possible and then here this is also an
idea the point is that things like that
are not that clear it looks nice because
of that but I have counterplay yeah when
I opened up the aged father he five
point is vulnerable so it's not a
totally straightforward thing this
position yeah it but the deserved loss I
guess I really was worse most of the
time thanks for watching